merci même la ministre la parole et à
monsieur fernand siré pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur tous
les étés dans mon département des
pyrénées orientales et dans des communes
qui répondent parfaitement aux
dispositions de la loi en matière
d'aires d'accueil de des convois
comptant plusieurs dizaines et centaines
de caravanes s'implante de matières
illicites sur des terrains municipaux où
ceux des propriétés privées
on a ainsi de véritables villes
temporaire qui s'installe provoquant des
difficultés en matière notamment de
réserves d'eau et d'assainissement
face à cela on ne dispose d'aucun moyen
juridique en raison de la complexité des
procédures pour obtenir l'éviction des
campements illicites dans des délais
satisfaisants
les gens du voyage peuvent s'installer
illégalement sur un terrain pour la
durée de leur choix sans jamais courir
le moindre risque de subir une sanction
et s'autorisant ainsi même à faire du
chantage auprès des autorités ont créé
de véritables zones de non droit
les communes sont à bout de souffle et
non plus les moyennes de réparer les
dégâts provoqués lors des installations
sauvages ou lors des manifestations de
contestation
le problème réside dans le fait que ces
personnes semblent répondre un statut à
part
alors qu'on condamne avec les hommes le
communautarisme comment peut-on adapter
cette situation les tensions montent les
français sont exonérés de cette justice
à deux vitesses ainsi est urgent de
donner plus de droits aux communes et
plus de moyens juridiques à leurs élus
afin d'équilibrer leurs droits et leurs
devoirs
tels étaient les objectifs de la
proposition de loi de notre groupe
défend de il a quelques semaines et que
votre majorité a préféré balayer d'un
revers de main
les français et leurs représentants ont
besoin d'être écoutés par un
gouvernement qui prend ses
responsabilités et qui agit pour les
valeurs les valeurs de la république
qu'elle soit respectée mais cohésif je
cire et en droits et en devoirs
la parole est à madame sylvia pinel
ministre du logement merci madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député vous avez
raison de dire que les sujets liés à
l'accueil et à l'habitat des gens du
voyage sont importants et le
gouvernement a bien conscience qu'il
préoccupe nos élus et nos concitoyens la
majorité des collectivités locales font
de réels efforts pour remplir leurs
obligations au regard du schéma
départemental des gens du voyage en lien
avec les préfets et le bon respect de ce
schéma permet aux services de l'état de
faire exécuter les mises en demeure avec
efficacité
c'est aussi dans ce sens que nous avons
travaillé notamment avec dominique
raimbourg pour adopté en première
lecture ici en juin dernier une
proposition de loi après un long travail
et un important travail de concertation
avec l'ensemble des acteurs et je veux
d'ailleurs salué l'implication de
dominique raimbourg et de nombreux élus
ce texte garantit davantage de moyens
d'action efficace et opérationnel pour
les mères mais il met aussi fin aux
régimes administratifs spécifiques et
discriminant réservé aux gens du voyage
et qui leur impose la possession d'un
carnet et d'un livret de circulation car
un vivre ensemble apaisé suppose
l'égalité des droits
mais ce texte monsieur le député
renforce également les procédures
d'évacuation à disposition des élus en
prévoyant que lorsqu une caravane
procède dans un délai de sept jours à un
stationnement en violation d'un arrêté
même d'interdiction sur le territoire de
la commune ou de cette intercommunalité
et qui portent atteinte à l'ordre public
alors la mise en demeure continue de
s'appliquer
ce texte est donc un texte d'équilibré
et le gouvernement souhaite continuer à
avancer
sur ce sujet de manière concrète et
pragmatique mais surtout de manière
apaisée et respectueuse dans l'intérêt
du vivre ensemble de notre république
merci madame la ministre